well we got a lot today we got a lot
today i know you're in lake george
because a lot happened this weekend
we got to take a peek at kanye because
kanye he renoun he said he wasn't
running for president
but now he he apparently is continuing
to campaign
the kid was up there in a security vest
like he looked like he was an iraqi
american contractor and then jesus and
his
and then he's got like red hair and uh
he broke down in tears and he made it
let's take a little peek mikey if we can
and what he said about our favorite
harriet tuckman i mean he went
full harriet tuchman on harriet tubman
let's hear it even move when harriet
tubman
will harry and tubman never actually
freed the slaves jesus had the slaves go
work for other white people y'all we
leaving right now
so that's a stephen yeah yeah
because yeah yeah kanye is going to sue
us for coming up with reality as a
suggestion
because we talk it he lives it yeah he
lives it kanye west is
what the little man that lives inside me
it's it's kanye west because
he is actually i mean if he gets on the
ballot i'll vote for him i'll vote for
kanye would you
absolutely i just i just think that when
you watch that you go okay that's what
comedy is now just take his meds and let
him go
let him go let him rip let him go so we
talk [ __ ] about harriet tuckman
let me ask you this do you think because
he was friends with
he was friends with trump and he
supported trump do you think that he's
doing this as a ploy with donald trump
to try to split the black vote
uh from biden and and so trump can have
a better chance you think this is a
do you think this is all a ploy i think
it's 100 percent a ploy
1 000 and i think that
joe biden was hired by the russians
that's what i think
and i think trump knows that and i think
trump that's why trump and kanye
got together because they know that
biden and pelosi and schumer and all
those dems
are russian operatives and they don't
want to have a chance of them winning at
all
so they say kanye will split the black
vote with trump and then america will
stay in the state it will stay safe in
the hands of our emperor
right that's what it is yeah here we go
here's another little clip of kanye
because my dad was too busy
this is uh yeah you're watching mental
it's a mental breakdown and guess what
antifa and any this is what you wanted
so this is what you get this is your
country so there you go you're welcome
yeah there it is kanye kind of is kanye
billionaire he's pretty close to it
he's pretty close to it he's running for
president the media is showing up to
listen to him
because i know we we are have been in
the past a systemically racist country
but we've made a we've made a lot of
progress when
big time when when press show up to
listen to what that guy says
i mean he's a black guy and he's also
pretty close to a billionaire
yeah i don't know who's stopping that
guy yep he's the billionaire uh
muffin chomps is letting us know he's a
billionaire and he took a pp loan
ppe loan from uncle trump so yeah so
that's what it is
it's just what it is i mean you know
i mean yeah but it's what it is i mean
o.j simpson cut
his wife's head off and and he didn't go
to jail
there's a lot of black people that did
go to jail for committing crimes in the
past but
in some in some small way when oj cut
his wife's head off and got away with it
it's kind of progress no it's progress
but that was the beginning of progress
thank you guys so much for watching we
hope you loved it don't forget to click
subscribe
and turn your alerts on and go to
patreon.com for more fun where things
get really
[Music]